all right Michelle who bought your pulse
racing faster McDreamy or McSteamy
oh listen okay so the McDreamy story
line but two words for you the towel mix
female man let's get hot in here just
thinking about there's a possible go
after all that that Grey's Anatomy has
actually found a new doctor that's even
hotter Lord helpless people on land now
you layer I got the first appointment
you know a lot of fans are already
trying to ship your character with
Ellen's how are you feeling about that
hey you know whatever happens happens I
look at Twitter it's like well he's not
McSteamy well he's not McDreamy
Twitter's dubbed him makan tree that's
because Gray's new ortho God was best
known for his role as a singer on
Nashville before that Chris Carmack was
known for this infamous line on the OC
welcome video see [ __ ] welcome to the
o.r [ __ ] that's for you in real life
the 37 year old just said I do to his
longtime girlfriend Erin slaver their
daughter Chi was the flower girl my
daughter calls me doctor daddy now
Chris's short new do was a plot point in
next week's episode but tonight we find
out about his secret past with Chuck we
just waited tables together he's like my
brother but do you ever wonder how does
Gray's pull off those crazy medical
scenes meet Linda Klein the show's
technical advisor she showed us what
they call the wall of horror filled with
the prosthetics used for all 15 seasons
this is a Elisabeth Reiser she played
one of our characters that was our Jane
Doe this is our go-to and it's got Foley
his wife was here and we put him on the
table and she walked in the room and
honest to god she recognized him right
other great secrets they use cream
cheese and jelly for blood and when in
the o.r Chris had to learn one thing
both hands on the drill you know I was
like all right let's drill
[Music]
[Applause]